After months of waiting and speculation, the
full trailer for the eighth and final season
of Game of Thrones has finally arrived ahead
of the premiere on April 14.
From dragons at Winterfell to significant
glasses of wine, here are some small details
you may have missed.
Greyjoy family infighting took up a lot of
time in the seventh season.
Good things happened for Theon, who reclaimed
his name after being tortured by Ramsay Bolton.
But Yara, his formidable older sister, was
captured and held hostage by conniving uncle
Euron, hoping to provoke Theon into retaliating.
Euron currently holds all the power in the
situation, with his fleet having destroyed
Yara's ships.
Though he seems to serve Cersei, it's more
likely that he's simply looking out for his
own interests.
It's clear that at least one Greyjoy ship
is on the move in the new trailer, where a
ship bearing the Greyjoy sigil is seen stocked
with an entire army.
The leader of the ship is sporting gold armor
and slicked-back blond hair; whoever it is,
it's a sure sign that we haven't seen the
last of the Greyjoy family conflict.
In the final moments of season seven, the
Night King used his new ice dragon to demolish
the Wall, setting up an intense scenario for
the final season.
Viewers were also concerned about the fate
of two characters who were guarding the Wall
when it fell - Tormund and Beric Dondarrion.
"It's a long way down."
"Yeah.
The crows keep telling me I'll get used to
it."
Fan favorite Tormund has been winning over
audiences for years, so viewers were devastated
by the possibility of his death.
But Beric is known for surviving almost anything
through red magic, so it seemed possible that
he could still be alive.
Thankfully, the trailer gave anxious fans
a glimpse of both Tormund and Beric, flaming
sword and all.
The most explosive secret revealed during
the sixth season was that Jon Snow is not
Ned Stark's illegitimate son, but actually
Aegon Targaryen, rightful heir to the Iron
Throne.
He's also the nephew to Daenerys Targaryen,
with whom he has recently struck up a new,
problematic romance.
"We don't choose whom we love."
Currently, the lovers remain blissfully ignorant
to their family ties, and the only characters
with any concrete knowledge of Jon's lineage
are Bran Stark and Sam Tarly, who haven't
gotten the chance to tell him yet.
This trailer has a few shots hinting at when
Jon and Daenerys might find out about each
other.
There's a moment between the two in the crypts
of Winterfell, where Jon's mother Lyanna is
buried, as well as a moment with the two of
them approaching the dragons together, which
might mean Jon is taking a ride on one this
season.
Jon can also be seen lingering in the godswood,
a place that's been very important to the
Stark family.
There's also a shot of Sam and Bran looking
furtively at someone offscreen, which could
be the moment just before they break the news
to Jon about his new girlfriend.
The trailer shows both of Daenerys' remaining
dragons arriving at Winterfell, stunning Sansa
as she stands on the ramparts.
Fans already knew that the dragons would return
for the final season, as they will play an
instrumental part in the war against the White
Walkers, but Viserion, Daenerys' third dragon
who fell during a battle with the Night King,
is conspicuously absent from the trailer.
There's a lot of questions surrounding Viserion's
return, like whether or not Daenerys will
be able to control him, or if he might return
to his former self.
In enemy hands, he's a game changer, and leaving
him out of the trailer feels significant.
Throughout Game of Thrones, Gendry has remained
an enigma.
As one of the only surviving bastards of King
Robert Baratheon, he has been hunted and in
hiding for most of the series.
But though he has a significant claim to the
Iron Throne, he doesn't seem to want control
of the Seven Kingdoms - as an apprentice blacksmith,
he seems more concerned with surviving than
ruling.
Gendry's long absence was resolved in season
seven, with the reveal that he's still working
as a blacksmith.
In the season eight trailer, he seems to be
forging swords, which is important in the
leadup to the final battle.
With the White Walkers on the move, Westeros
needs Valyrian steel swords more than ever,
and Gendry may be just the man for the job.
Audiences see two glimpses of Cersei Lannister
during the trailer, and they couldn't be more
different - first, she's standing triumphantly
on the shores of King's Landing, flanked by
the sycophantic Qyburn and her undead bodyguard.
She looks completely in control.
But in her next shot, she's alone in a quiet
throne room, holding a glass of wine and seemingly
on the verge of tears.
Last time we saw Cersei clutching wine on
the Iron Throne, it was during season 2's
"Blackwater," when she thought the city was
about to fall, so to mimic that moment seems
significant.
Also, last season saw her shock her family
by revealing that she was pregnant with Jaime's
baby.
After the reveal, she began to conspicuously
decline alcohol, so we have to wonder what
happens to make Cersei pick up the bottle
again.
One of the longest-running couples of the
entire show came to an apparent end during
the seventh season, when Jaime Lannister left
his sister behind to help protect Westeros.
He's disgusted that Cersei would choose stay
out of the fight against the White Walkers,
so he leaves King's Landing, apparently heading
to Winterfell to join his brother Tyrion against
Cersei's wishes.
Even though there's still time for Jaime to
return to his sister's side, he seems to be
sticking to his guns in the trailer - though
it's not revealed where he is, fans can guess
that he may have arrived at Winterfell, as
he tells an unseen character that he promised
to fight for the living - not just the Lannisters.
"I intend to keep that promise."
Since Jaime is seen elsewhere in the trailer
bloodied and fighting at a castle that may
well be Winterfell, it seems like he may just
turn against Cersei after all.
Throughout the trailer, glimpses of battles
pop up here and there, but thanks to plenty
of fire and smoke, it's still unconfirmed
where those particular scenes take place.
However, in the final shot of the trailer,
viewers clearly see Daenerys' Army of Unsullied
alongside Brienne of Tarth, her loyal squire
Podrick Payne, and Daenerys' closest advisor
Jorah Mormont waiting in front of Winterfell
as a ghostly horse's leg quietly takes a step
towards them, indicating the fate of Westeros
may come down to a massive battle at Winterfell,
where the series introduced us to its world
years ago.
We hope they've got enough Valyrian steel.
We know Brienne has a Valyrian sword, but
the rest of the army could be woefully underprepared.
Hope somebody brought the dragons.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.